في السرير ظاهره تتحول الى تريند على منصه
تيك توك وتثير جدلا واسعا وسط تحضير
الخبراء من خطرها على صحه الانسان فما هي
هذه الظاهره
[موسيقى]
التعفن في السرير هو قيام الشخص بالبقاء
في سريره لايام تحت طبقات من البطانيات
وفي كثير من الاحيان مع هاتف او وجبه
خفيفه في متناول اليد مع العزوف عن القيام
بايه نشاطات ويشير المصطلح ايضا الى حاله
تثقل التي تستوجب راحه طويله او استسلام
للرغبه بالبقاء في السرير التي تنتابون في
بعض الاوقات حين نستيقظ صباحا
واستخدمون على منصه تيك توك شاركوا
فيديوهات اظهرت بقائهم في السرير ليوم
كامل ومشاهده التلفاز او تصفح الانترنت
فيما حضر خبراء في كليه الطب جامعه واشنطن
في سات لويس من البقاء في السرير لاكثر من
يوم او يومين ووصفوا الامر بالمقلق ويمكن
ان يشير الى مشاكل عقليه مختلفه واوصوا
بالتحدث الى معالج في حال تحولت هذه
الظاهره الى ادمان